the layer one is is the property
settlement layer and we're we're going
to do 350 000 transactions or less a day
100 million transactions a year is the
bandwidth on the layer one and
it would be an ideal layer of one to
move a billion dollars from point A to
point B with the massive security
the role of the layer one is is two
things
one thing is I want to move a large sum
of money through space
with security I I can move
any amount of Bitcoin in a matter of
minutes
for dollars on layer one
that the second important
feature of the layer one is I need the
money to last forever
right I need the money indestructible
Immortal so so the bigger trick is not
to move a billion dollars from here to
Tokyo the big trick is to move a billion
dollars from here to the year 2140.
and uh and that's that's what we want to
solve with layer one and and the best
real metaphor in New York City would be
the the granite or the schist
what you want is a city block of of
bedrock and how long has it been there
like millions of years it's been there
and how fast you want it to move you
don't yeah in fact the single thing
that's most important is that it not
deflect if it deflects a foot in a
hundred years it's too much if it
deflects an inch and 100 years you might
not want that so the layer one of
Bitcoin is a foundation upon which you
put weight how much weight can you put
on it we put a trillion 10 trillion 100
trillion a quadrillion how much weights
on the bedrock in in Manhattan right
think about 100 story buildings so that
the real key there is the foundational
asset needs to be there at all so the
fact that you can create
a hundred trillion dollar layer of one
that would stand for a hundred years
that is the Revolutionary breakthrough
first time and the fact that it's
ethical right it's ethical and it's
common property Global permissionless
extremely unlikely that would happen
people tried 50 times before and they
all failed they try 15 000 times after
and they've all been they've all
generally failed 98 have failed and a
couple have like been less successful
but for the most part
that's an extraordinary thing now just
really quickly pause just to Define some
terms people don't know layer one is uh
that Michael's referring to is in
general what people know of as the
Bitcoin technology originally defined
which is the blockchain there's a
consensus mechanism of proof of work a
low number of transactions but you can
move a very large amount of money the
reason he's using the term layer one is
now that there's a lot of ideas of layer
two technologies built on top of this
Bedrock that allow you to move a much
larger number of transactions
um
so sort of uh higher frequency I don't
know how what terminology I want to use
but basically be able to use now
something that is based on bitcoin to
then uh buy stuff be a consumer to
transfer money to use it as currency
um just to Define some terms
yeah
so the layer one is the foundation for
the entire cyber economy
and um
we don't want it to move fast what we
want what we want is is immortality
incorrupt Immortal and corruptible and
destructible
right that that's what you want
Integrity from the layer one now there's
Layer Two and layer three and Layer Two
I would Define as an open permissionless
non-custodial protocol
that uses uh the underlying layer one
token as it's as its gas fee so what's
custodial mean and how does the
different markets like uh is lightning
Network so lightning Network would be an
example of a layer two non-custodial so
the lightning network will sit on top of
uh of layer one it'll sit on top of
Bitcoin and it solves the what you want
to do is solve the problem of
it's well and fine I don't want to move
a billion dollars every day what I want
to move is five dollars
a billion times a day
so if I want to move five dollars a
billion times a day I don't really need
to put the entire trillion dollars of
assets at risk every time I move five
dollars all I really need to do is put a
hundred thousand dollars in a Channel or
a million dollars in a channel and then
I do 10 million transactions where I
have a million dollars at risk and of
course it's it's kind of simple if I if
I put
if I lower my security requirement by a
factor of a million I can probably move
the stuff a million times faster right
and that's how lightning works it's
non-custodial because there is no
there's no Corporation or custodian or
counterparty you're trusting
right there's a there's the risk of
moving through the channel
but um lightning is an example of how I
go from 350 000 transactions a day to
350 million transactions a day so on
that layer too you could move the
Bitcoin in seconds for fractions of
pennies now
that's not the end-all be-all because
the truth is there are a lot of open
protocols lightning probably won't be
the only one they're you know there's a
open market competition of other
permissionless open source protocols to
do this work
um and in theory
any any other crypto Network that was
deemed to be property deemed to be
non-security you would all you could
also think of as potentially a layer two
to bitcoin right there's a debate about
are there any and what are they and and
we could leave that for a later time but
why do you think of them as Layer Two as
opposed to contending for layer one
yeah actually if they're using their own
token then they are a layer one if you
create an open protocol that uses the
Bitcoin token as the as the fee then it
becomes a layer two okay right Bitcoin
itself right incentivizes its own
transactions with its own token and
that's what makes it layer one
okay what's layer three then Layer Three
is a custodial layer so if you want to
move Bitcoin in milliseconds for free
you move it through binance or coinbase
or cash app
so this is a very straightforward thing
I mean it seems pretty obvious when you
think about it that there are going to
be hundreds of thousands of layer threes
there may be dozens of layer twos there
might I mean lightning is A1 but it's
not the only one anybody can invent
something
right and and
we can have this debate about custodial
non-custodial
um
don't you think there's a Mana
monopolization possibilities at layer
three
so
um
you know coin you mentioned binance coin
coinbase what if they start to dominate
and basically everybody's using them
practically speaking and then it becomes
too costly to memorize the uh the
private key in your brain
I mean or like a cold storage of Lair
one technology the idealists fear the
layer threes because they think and
especially they detest they would detest
a bit
there's almost like a layer four by the
way if you want to a layer four would be
I've got Bitcoin on an application but I
can't withdraw it
so I've got an application that's backed
by Bitcoin but the Bitcoin is sealed
it's it's a proprietary example and I'll
give you an example of that that would
be like um grayscale
if I own a share of gbtc and and so I
own a security actually you know you
could own mstr if you own a security or
you own a product that has Bitcoin
embedded in it you get the benefits of
Bitcoin but you don't have the ability
to withdraw the asset to give the
security Market at layer four and my
understanding this correctly
I don't know if I would say
I don't not all Securities are layer
four but but anything that's a
proprietary product based upon with
Bitcoin embedded in it where you can't
withdraw the Bitcoin is another
application of Bitcoin so if if you
think about different ways you can use
this you can either stay completely on
the layer one and use the base chain for
your transactions or you can limit
yourself to layer one and Layer Two
lightning and the purist would say we
stay there get your Bitcoin off the
exchange
but you could also go to the layer three
when cash app uh supported Bitcoin they
made it very easy to buy it and then
they gave you the withdrawal when PayPal
or I think Robin Hood let you buy it
they wouldn't let you withdraw it and it
was a big Community uproar and people
want they want these layer threes to to
make it possible to withdraw the Bitcoin
so you can take it to your own private
wallet and get it off the exchange
I think the answer to the question of
well is is corruption possible is
corruption is possible and all human
institutions and all governments
everywhere the difference between
digital property and physical property
is when you own a building in Los
Angeles and the city politics turn
against you you can't move the building
yeah and when you own a share of a
security that's like a U.S traded
security and you wish to move to some
other country you can't take the
security with you either and when you
own a bunch of gold and you try to get
through the airport they might not let
you take it so
Bitcoin is advantageous versus all those
because you actually do have the option
to withdraw your asset from The Exchange
and if you you know if you had Bitcoin
with Fidelity and you had shares of
stock with Fidelity and if you had uh
bonds and sovereign debt with Fidelity
if you own some some you know mutual
funds and some other random limited
Partnerships with Fidelity none of those
things could be removed from the
custodian but the Bitcoin you can take
off uh The Exchange you can remove from
the custodian so
so uh it's still possible there's a
deterrent there's a deterrent that's an
anti-corrupting element and the phrase
is an armed Society it's a polite
Society
right because you have the optionality
to withdraw all your assets from the
crypto exchange you can enforce fairness
and at the point where you disagree with
their policies you can within an hour
move your assets to another counterparty
or take personal custody of those assets
and you don't have that option with most
other forms of property maybe you don't
have as much optionality with any other
form of property on Earth and so what
what makes digital property distinct
is the fact that it has the most
optionality for custody
now coming back to this digital energy
issue the real key point is the energy
moves in milliseconds for free on layer
threes
it moves in seconds or less than seconds
on layer twos it moves in minutes on the
layer one
and it I don't think it makes any sense
to even think about trying to solve all
three problems on the layer one because
it's impossible to achieve the security
and the incorruptibility and immortality
if you try to build that much speed and
that functionality and performance
in fact
if you come back to the New York model
you really wanted a block of granite a
building and a company
that's what makes the economy
right if you said if I said to you
you're going to build a building but you
can only have one company in it for the
life of the building it would be very
fragile like very brittle what company a
hundred years ago is still relevant
today if you want all three layers
because they all oscillate at different
frequencies and and you know there's a
tendency to think well it's it's got to
be this L1 or that L1 not really and
sometimes people think well I don't
really want any L3
but companies
it's not an even War companies are
better
than uh crypto asset networks at certain
things if you want complexity you want
to implement complexity or you want to
implement compliance
or customer service right companies do
these things well right we know it
you couldn't decentralize apple or
Netflix or even YouTube the performance
wouldn't be there
and the subtlety wouldn't be there and
you can't really legally decentralize
certain forms of banking and insurance
because they will become illegal in the
political jurisdiction they're in so
unless you're a crypto Anarchist and you
believe in no companies and no nation
states
right
which is just not very practical not
anytime soon once you allow that nation
states will continue and companies have
a role then the layered architecture
follows and
the free market determines who wins for
example
there are layer threes that uh that let
you acquire Bitcoin and withdraw Bitcoin
there are there are other applications
that let you acquire but not withdraw it
and and they're they don't get the same
market share but they might give you
some other advantage
there are there are certain layer threes
like Jack dorsey's cash app where they
just Incorporated lightning an
implementation of it so
uh Into Cash app so that makes it more
that makes it advantageous versus uh an
application that doesn't incorporate
lightning
if you think about
the big picture the big picture is eight
billion people with mobile phones served
by a hundred million companies doing
billions of transactions an hour
and and the companies are settling with
each other on the base layer in blocks
of 80 million at a time and then the
companies are trading with the consumers
right in uh proprietary layers like
layer three and then
on occasion people are shuffling assets
across custodians with lightning Layer
Two because you don't want to pay five
dollars to move fifty dollars you want
to pay a 20th of a penny to move fifty
dollars
and so all of these things create
efficiency in the economy
and likes if you want to consider how
much efficiency
if if you gave me a billion dollars in
20 years I couldn't find a way to trade
with another company or a counterparty
in Nigeria mm-hmm like no no amount of
money give me 10 billion dollars I
couldn't do it
because you get shut down at the banking
level you can't link up a bank in
Nigeria with the bank in the U.S you get
shut down at this credit card level
because they don't have the credit card
so they won't clear
you get shut down at the at the
compliance fcpa level because
because uh you know you wouldn't be able
to implement A system that interfaced
with somebody else's system if it's not
in the right political jurisdiction
on the other hand three entrepreneurs in
Nigeria on the weekend could create a
website that would trade in this
lightning economy using open protocols
without asking anybody's permission
so you're talking about something that's
like a million times cheaper less
friction and faster to do it if you want
it if you want to get money to move